[Music]
damnit wall-e
what'd I say uh I was supposed to save
some of the bad guys for you just a few
you know what I'll make it up to you
first round is on me no thanks man we're
good I actually have a girl waiting for
me next time congratulations everyone
they finally decided what to do with
Bali West it is pretty much what
everybody thought he's gonna go on
legends of tomorrow and be a series
regular there for most of the rest of
their season
now they're a couple moves that they're
making in pursuit of that that I'll
explain it's not quite so simple like
it's not like the next time that legends
of tomorrow comes back he's gonna be a
series regular there are a couple other
things that he's doing this season and
he'll always be a flash character first
so he's always gonna come back to the
flash TV show but you can kind of see
how they had trouble fitting him in and
giving him an arc this season with
everything that's going on with a
thinker and the other characters and
tried to introduce elongated man then
you have all this potential for women on
the show being pregnant having babies
later this season and it just gets
really complicated it's much easier to
send Wally to a TV show that actually
needs him because it just lost both
halves of firestorm and I know there's a
lot of questions about why that happened
and why those actors left it's not quite
what you think but because this is such
a huge deal of course there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway or
Legion ring if you guys want all you
have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment about
Wally on the video so Wally stuff first
the last time we heard about him was in
the mid-season finale on the flash they
said that he was in Cambodia we don't
know exactly what he was doing I've done
a couple of videos about how they do
weave in Easter eggs for Titans and
other TV shows like fighting a starfish
from outer space
self-reflection and the battle with a
starfish from out of space
gives you perspective
[Music]
so those are largely Easter eggs I think
that they always knew that he was gonna
go to legends of tomorrow what they said
is this during legends episode 11 he'll
appear briefly then later in episode 13
that's when he becomes a series regular
and then I think he'll just be around
for the rest of their season right up
until episode 18 that may be like right
before then he goes back to the flash
for the flash finale
because I don't think they're gonna end
this season of the flash without Wally
around because I do think that they're
gonna pay off some of those we're gonna
need more diapers Easter eggs and you
don't want to leave Wally out because
he's part of the flash family they're
doing a lot of flash family things this
year but for the most part the rest of
the year Wally West is going to be on
legends of tomorrow helping them with
their time aberrations with malice in
the new version of the Legion of Doom
and people are wondering if maybe the
reverse flash is going to be malice I
don't think that's the case I think it's
something that's a little bit different
what is this
[Music]
no unendurable pain
there is a rumor that the EU barth on
reverse-flash is gonna make an
appearance in episode 15 of the flash
this season but that's unconfirmed but
Matt ledger just signed on to another TV
show as a series regular so I don't
think that he's gonna be around in a big
way for the rest of the flash this year
or the first half of next season so
that's somewhat unrelated to what's
going on with Wally's so we can talk
about it during a separate video for the
most part Wally will be a legends
character then he'll come back he'll
help out team flash and who knows what
will happen with him in season 5 it's a
little too soon to predict what's gonna
happen during flash season 5 depending
on how they pay off some of the Easter
eggs they set up at the beginning of the
season but for the most part everybody
guessed correctly like 99% of people
were like you know what if he's gonna go
somewhere else that's probably going to
be legends because they have that
special handshake in Episode one it
implies you already bros and the tone of
his character just fits with the tone of
Legends and for those that are wondering
why firestorm left Victor Garber
decided to leave separately from the
actor that plays Jax so you know two
different reasons for leaving the show
Victor Garber left because he wants to
do more theater in New York and he can't
do that when he's in Vancouver he just
doesn't like to be in Vancouver all the
time just doing legends like more
recently he showed up on the Orval so he
just wants to do other things and that's
also kind of the reason why Jax left
although he's a younger actor he just
doesn't have that much experience so he
just wants to do other productions I
don't know that there was any
dissatisfaction with the actors and the
direction of the show or anything like
that so it's a totally normal thing
actors want to leave the show because
they want to do other projects it
happens all the time on every TV show
wall-e is now the most powerful
character on Legends so it'll be funny
to see how they use his character but if
you forgot there is a Constantine
two-part episode when Legends comes back
that's gonna start on February 12th and
that'll be a Monday night so legends is
a Monday night TV show now because Black
Lightning airs after the flash so I'll
remind everybody when we get ready for
that it's gonna be a couple more weeks
before it gets here it'll drop the same
week that Black Panther hits theaters
for those of you that are asking about
Wally West on Titans now like what does
this mean for him potentially being a
Titans character so like I've said
before
what I think will happen is eventually
they will do a speedster on that TV show
but just not during season one they
already have so many characters so
they'll do their 13 episodes then we'll
figure out what's going on with titan
season 2 because it already does sound
like they're planning for a season 2 I
did a Titans video yesterday about how
certain circumstances and distribution
can make it easier for them to
greenlight multiple seasons whereas
traditional network television is so
dependent on ratings and what's
happening in the moment but we'll get
some more information about season 1 of
Titans pretty soon so no worries about
that they've still only build the first
couple of episodes so there's still a
bunch of new characters that they have
not announced yet like we still haven't
heard about Donna Troy although we did
hear about a character that sounds a lot
like her there's a new girl right all I
can say is that she's a wonderful
addition to the team but for those of
you hoping to see Wally West on a Titans
team in the future do not worry
it's still totally possible but in the
way that Black Lightning is kind of
connected to the air verse but not
really I think it's gonna be the same
situation with Titans where it's DC TV
but the producers decide when and where
characters are allowed to crossover and
probably not going to happen during
season one but everybody just freaked
out about Wally going on legends in the
comments and here's that Constantine
trailer for the next episode of legends
again it's going to be pretty cold so no
worries I will do videos for Wally and
Constantine on legends
their hope
they tell you don't like horror movies
DC's legends of tomorrow what's gonna
happen next is is there was a whole
bunch of Marvel Avengers stuff that just
dropped spider-man is supposed to show
up during the venom movie now so I'll
explain what's going on with that I'll
try to get the videos out as fast as
possible there's also a new olan rogers
animated TV show in the vein of Rick and
Morty that's gonna premiere next week
it's called final space I'll do a
trailer video for that tomorrow
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner dean Allanson please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name another new winner
when I post new DC this weekend thank
you so much for coming
click here for that Titans video and
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight